rise and grind it's a new day full of
new opportunities new possibilities and
in this very video we're gonna be
talking about how to hack the youtube
algorithm and three tips
for getting your videos recommended
getting your videos
suggested by youtube so that you can get
more views and get more subscribers
and this is based on an article
and post that youtube themselves did
it's information straight from the
source and we're going to be reading
their line by line tips basically
so we can get an insight basically from
behind the curtain like if we're curious
what the wizard of oz
is doing with the youtube algorithm this
article reveals
some insights and check this out the
youtube algorithm
decides what people watch on youtube 70
of the time according to pew research
center 81
of american youtube users say they
regularly watch videos recommended by
the algorithm so let me know what
does youtube recommend for you to watch
like what kind of videos do you watch
the most what's being recommended to you
right now
and um have you noticed that so much of
your consumption is by the next
recommended video from
youtube here's the big idea if you can
get your videos recommended by youtube
it's actually the biggest key to
explosive
growth and so over the last year at
think media
our other channel suggested videos
accounted for 21
of our overall traffic we got 37 million
views over the last year
and check this out it's hard to read but
it says youtube
53.1 of the impressions that's when
people have a chance to click on one of
your videos like
it shows up on the recommended or
somewhere else and just the thumbnail
goes past their vision right
53.1 percent of those impressions came
from
youtube recommending my content
what this is crazy makes me think of
like youtube holding up a billboard
of your thumbnail and being like you
want to watch it you want to watch it
you want to watch it you want to click
on this video
and so out of that 21 million views
came from those impressions so figuring
out how to really crack the code on
their algorithm is huge
so if you are fired up and ready for
today's content
um smash the like button if you're ready
to grow your youtube channel because i'm
going to be breaking down some of the
things i've learned from growing
multiple youtube channels
and from helping others do that as well
and click subscribe if you're not
subscribed for more content like this
and we're going to get straight into the
content but by the way if we're just
meeting
my name is shawn and my passion is
helping you
build your influence with youtube this
is the coffee with kennel
show let me know what you're drinking
during the first
part of the show i go through like a
tactical training and today is like a
web class
on how youtube works and then during the
second part i bring
you on and answer your questions about
youtube to help you grow further faster
or social media business and how you can
actually grow your
impact as well as your profits with
youtube
and so today though we're talking about
how the youtube algorithm works three
tips for getting your videos suggested
by youtube
and this is part two in part one we
talked about how youtube search
works this is how youtube
recommendations work now
it should be known that youtube
recommendations in youtube search
or rather suggested 70 of traffic on
youtube comes from that
for most people it's their biggest
traffic source for think media
it's actually our second biggest traffic
source we focus heavily on search
to this day this is the age-old debate
between uh youtube experts and youtube
creators
but really which one's better if you
want explosive growth
recommendations are better however it's
almost like investing
you have like surefire bets and or safe
conservative investing and then you have
like big swings for the fences type of
investing i like doing a little bit of
both i like to go for the big swings
viral videos more time put into the
content hoping that it breaks out in the
algorithm
but one of the reasons why i love search
is because it's more practical it's a
little
it's more slow and steady wins people
don't have patience for it
and that's why they miss out on that
opportunity but really it's not
either or it's both and and so in part
one we talk about how youtube search
works now we're in part two talking
about how youtube recommendations works
and today's video is brought to you by
tubestarterkit.com
if you haven't heard yet we are doing a
special holiday
sale on our youtube starter kit you can
get over 90
off and what it is is a power packed
template and tutorial bundle
that will dramatically shortcut your
path to better
youtube videos starting right now and
it'll help you start youtube right or
maybe you need to revive
and bring fresh life into your current
youtube channel
tubestarterkit.com and the sale is
incredible over 90 off and so you can
see details in the description down
below
um of today's video
listen this is quotes from youtube now
with over 500 hours of content oh
uploaded to youtube every minute finding
what you need would be nearly impossible
with some help sorting through
all the videos one way youtube does that
is by ranking videos in search and
another way is recommendations
and the videos that they're showing you
that cut through all
the noise so how does youtube
recommendations
work well let's read this
recommendations help you discover
more of the videos you love now let's
just stop there
we're going to say this a lot in this
video and it's that the content creator
who understands
the viewer best wins you need to
understand
the viewer that you want to reach and
what do they love
now youtube's advice here is written in
terms of how recommendations works for
your consumption
but if you're watching this video on
think media or think marketing
you are here as a creator so you're also
trying to understand viewers as a
content creator
but ultimately what it comes down to is
they're saying listen recommendations is
trying to
understand the viewer youtube is trying
to understand the viewer
figure out what the viewers passions are
what the viewer loves what the viewers
behaviors are
and give them more of what they love for
example
it could be a great new recipe to try or
your next favorite song
we share recommendations both on
youtube's homepage
and in the up next section as a
suggestion
of what to watch next when you're
writing a video
so this is again coming straight from
the wizard of odd oz youtube
um youtube's homepage and the up next
they're saying are the two biggest
drivers of where that traffic comes from
so the first one's the home page so tell
me in the comments
what's on your homepage right this is a
combination of
a couple things this is going to be a
combination of channels i've subscribed
to
and maybe videos that are performing
well on their channels the hits
from videos that are maybe older like
i've got a hip-hop video from kyle
recommended it's two years old
but because i watched a kyle video
recently now it's recommending
one to me even though it's super old so
the best performing videos on your
youtube channel can be recommended on
people's home pages
it's important to know that no two
homepages are the same all your homepage
is different than mine is different than
your sisters is different than your
mom's
what's on your mom's homepage that's
what i really want to know um and so
it's going to be recommending and here's
what youtube's trying to do it literally
is trying to get you to watch stuff like
it's trying to recommend
the best videos that they think you'll
click on
based on your behavior so that's the
youtube home page let me know what's on
your home page
and then there's the up next so this is
the end of a video influencers video
based on me the viewer watching it's
small and hard to read on the screen
right now but it says up next
and then it actually recommends a
channel or a video from a different
channel now what's the common factor
sean cannell's in both videos i'm over
on video influencers i'm also
in this case on think marketing um maybe
the tags and the hashtags
but also it's recommending a video that
is um
also has 2021 in the title there's some
interesting things
point being that second huge driver is
that when a video ends youtube pushes
another video
now hopefully when one of your videos
ends it it pushes another one of your
video but a lot of times it'll actually
send people somewhere else
and your ultimate goal is that when
someone finishes a particular type of a
video
that you become the up next after
somebody else's video and we're gonna be
breaking down strategies and tips for
how you can do that in
this video so here's the factors that
youtube tells us
themselves number one behavior in
history number two context number three
quality and satisfaction number four
direct feedback
we're gonna explain what those are but
those are the four factors number one
behavior and history
and i quote we take into account many
signals
youtube is not telling all of us all the
signals but they are choosing to tell us
some of the signals
we take into account many signals
including your watch
history and search history
if enabled so as
as well as the channels you subscribe to
so let's break it down
the first factor of how youtube is
actually going to
determine what to recommend to you is
they're studying what you've watched
previously
so as soon as you start watching content
on youtube
youtube starts paying attention and
starts trying to algorithmically
figure out what to serve you next what's
interesting
is i don't even know and this is my
opinion that
whether your search history is enabled
or not if that even comes into play
i think youtube's watching no matter
what even if you're not logged in
case in point you go to your mom's house
for thanksgiving
you get on a computer that's not logged
into youtube you just start watching
content let's say you were on a web
browser that hadn't been used yet
because you like google chrome but your
mom only had safari installed on her mac
so you install google chrome it's a
total fresh login
and you start watching youtube content
at first
youtube's probably just going to start
recommending some of the most popular
stuff it has no clue it's just going to
lob out recommendations
but the more content you watch the more
detailed the recommendations are going
to become right
and so uh additionally
as you continue to watch content and
your
search history so you're also typing
things in search
so when you type in something how to
deep fry a turkey you know
dark meat versus white meat come on
which one are you do you eat turkey
number one and are you a dark meat or a
white me i'm a dark meat because i got
to get that rich flavor some people
they're not even comfortable they're
like scared of dark meat listen your
watch history
and your search history so as you
continue to search topics youtube is
getting data on you
and if you now have
a youtube account the channels you've
subscribed to
so the channels you're clicking
subscribe on youtube goes okay they're
interested in that type of content
it's probably assuming that those
channels are clear in the type of
content that they
are like if you subscribe to comedy
central youtube goes oh this person
wants more kind of comedy content
if you subscribe to the young turks or
phil defranco oh this person wants
cnn they want more news content oh if
you subscribe to
uh elevation church they go okay
maybe we'll recommend other praise and
worship music or other preachers
they're getting those details about you
with that
content based on your behavior and
history how can we use this
as creators first of all
what does youtube recommend to you i
really want you to start
studying your consumption and your
recommendations at another level i
believe
that even when you're chilling out and
you hang out
at the end of your work day when you're
hanging out with your family or by
yourself or with your cat or with your
dog
that if you get in front of your smart
tv do you watch youtube on your smart tv
that's i definitely watch youtube with
my apple tv i talked to siri
and i'm i'm watching it on my smart tv
and
and look at what is being recommended to
you you know i've been studying a lot of
running as i'm working my way up to a
marathon right now so all kinds of
running stuff's being recommended
interestingly enough ultra marathon
stuff and iron man stuff's been
recommended to me as well i don't even
know i was interested in it
now i want to run iron man in the next
five years like youtube's literally
shaping
like as they just keep feeding me more
stuff and i click through
we're listening to a lot of music so we
were listening to different stuff we
listened to different
you know uh stuff on the real estate
market or on the economy or health and
nutrition
what is being recommended to you and let
me know post in the comments down below
here's what's also fascinating video
consumption
is more important than subscribers in
2021.
subscribers are important but here's
what i mean even if you're not
subscribed to a channel
youtube as soon as you spend your time
listen you can
you can subscribe in one second but if
you spend 20 minutes on someone's
content youtube goes okay
this person has voted with their time
that they want to see more of this type
of content and so
my wife sonia and i we watch a lot of
these like uh tiny home videos
or we watch like this girl i think she's
in like iceland or norway or something
and it's just like these very peaceful
videos i watch these hiking videos
with like no sound they have sound but
no talking it's like 45 minutes of
like you want to talk about watch time i
turn it on my smart tv i let it play in
the other room
what are you watching and so to the
detail that you can uh pay attention to
that
and remember video consumption even if
you don't get a subscriber
because once someone once someone starts
hanging out on think media or think
marketing they might not be subscribed
yet i hope you're subscribed
but if you're watching this content
right now chances are tomorrow or when
you refresh in your homepage
will be another video with my face in it
because you voted with
your time by consuming the content so
how do we as creators leverage the
behavior in history
number one what channels is your target
audience subscribe to
so ask yourself that question if you are
unaware of what's happening in your
category in niche
then you're not really taking youtube
seriously as a creator yet
you got to move from dabbling to
dominating so that means you should do
market research
you need to understand like what other
channels is your audience subscribe to
why because
if if videos are being recommended to
people based on what they're subscribed
to and what they're watching
then how is your content related to
certain trends categories and topics
do some research what other channels are
they subscribed to you can use tools
like vid iq by the way to actually see
some of this information right and
there's also some new youtube features
so spend some time researching your
niche and your category if you haven't
blocked some time on your calendar
to actually research your category in
your niche
what are people talking about what kind
of videos are they making
and then what's being recommended to me
like that really is
like cream rises to the top no matter
how many cups of coffee you pour
eventually you don't really know the
watch minutes or whatever but once you
start seeing
certain videos you start you can study
the ones that actually have the most
most juice on them because youtube keeps
recommending them meaning
diverse audiences that have similar
thinking
are consuming that content and voting
with their watch time other signals
and therefore you're being shown the
video as well is this video intense yet
we're just getting started
buckle your seat belt i don't know if
you were ready for like
this is some pretty deep algorithmic
talk but here we go what kinds
of videos is your target audience
watching
so what kinds of videos are they
watching if you haven't really figured
out your niche my recommendation
is actually that you join
a proven and profitable niche yes in
your own way
but it's like indy 500 racing come on
you want to draft behind
some other you're not trying to be out
there especially when you're starting
what videos and content are already
winning and how can you draft behind
those videos so that you get recommended
and you get suggested and then what
trends are happening in your niche topic
or your category when you are aware
of trends when you are aware of the hot
topics
you might bring your point of view on
that and so someone is watching
like a good one's like the real estate
market crash of course because of
the pandemic and because of who knows
what's going on in the economy
and as we go into 2021 2020 is super
weird
can i get an amen and like and so
there's
a lot of people this whole it's kind of
a click-baity type title
but like you real estate market crash is
it
you know and i remember i watched one of
those videos next thing you know i've
watched six different videos from six
different people
there's certain titles that are trending
certain topics that are trending certain
angles that are trending and so when you
know that
you could start getting recommended
based on categories and groups of
audiences
behavior and history hit like if your
brain already hurts
listen the creator who understands the
viewer
best wins
what else do they watch who
else do they follow
what are they thinking you're like sean
it's hard that's why that's why i would
think man come on what are they thinking
what are they thinking
what do they like what
do they love what are they curious about
what are they paying attention to the
creator who understands the viewer best
wins you want to get more views you want
to hack the youtube algorithm you got to
understand
the viewer of your target audience not
all viewers
but the viewer that you want to reach
with your content
which brings us to tip number two
context and i quote youtube
we also consider your context such as
your country
and time of day for example this helps
us
show you locally relevant news
so therefore your homepage and your
recommendations are of course also based
on where you are
maybe time of day you're awake you know
why would i be being shown
news in australia when they're awake and
i'm asleep
and i might not even be interested when
i'm living in las vegas here in the
united states
youtube studying where i am they know my
ip address they know different things
so my home page might have recommended
local las vegas news might have
something related to nevada
etc this especially true with news but
this is relevant for us as creators as
well so how can we lean on this one
context ask yourself where does your
target audience live
i'm trying to reach the whole world well
you might want to start small you got to
start small before you get big
uh what's the best time of day to post
good question because you you want to
get that momentum
and that view velocity when the video
first comes out so that's
understanding the viewer and then what
is relevant for your local context like
this is really powerful you're a
business owner you're an entrepreneur
you're a real estate agent
thinking about local context you maybe
want to be recommended locally like i
would love to be a big fish in a small
pond if i'm trying to grow my local las
vegas real estate business
and i'm probably not going to do a ton
of deals in florida so
so just be thinking about what's
relevant to your local context
obviously keywords and your video titles
if they're city based or
if you have anything that is local you
can think about it something might
actually go viral locally first
but then people start being like oh my
gosh look what happened in michigan and
then it goes wider
and so context context is the second
thing that youtube gives us by the way i
put the articles and some bonus articles
for understanding the youtube algorithm
in the description as well number three
quality and satisfaction this is about
to get really real this is a pretty
dense
sentence this is one long sentence
another factor youtube's recommendation
systems consider
is whether other viewers who clicked
let's stop
clicked stop clicked what you got to
click on a video before
anything can happen so i want us to
remember
that your title your topic your
thumbnail are critical
because what's about to come next
doesn't even matter if you don't get the
click
so you've got to figure out how to get
attention with your title your topic
your thumbnail and then
we carry on so another factor
youtube recommendations systems consider
is whether others
who clicked on the same video
watched it to completion if you can get
someone to actually finish your video
you will trigger the algorithm hack the
algorithm and get
massive views and recommended a sign
people finishing it to completion is a
sign
that the video is higher quality or
enjoyable
so a way and number four reveals more
but a way that youtube is determining
if your video is high quality or
enjoyable is not the lighting
although that might help keep attention
it's not the camera although that might
actually speak to quality
quality is not about production value it
is about
content value it's about if the person
watches it or not
it's about does the person finish it or
not right
so assign to youtube that the video is
higher quality or enjoyable
is if they finish it or average view
duration how much of the video they
watch
or and listen and lean in for this one
or if they just clicked it and shortly
after starting
to view the video they clicked away
therefore
really getting good at titles and
thumbnails and topics is not good enough
because if someone just clicks it it's
like wow that was a great opening but
they
don't stick with it then it actually
ends up
hurting you it would end up hurting that
video because people go
youtube's like okay click through rate
is high but average view duration watch
time is like nothing people click away
the bounce rate um is is there
and so what does this all mean okay here
we go
so first for quality and satisfaction
tips for creators
you got to win the click you have to win
the click title
topic thumbnail second optimizing your
content if there's one thing
you always want to be thinking about is
leveling up your content optimizing your
content to hold viewers
attention trim the fluff how can you
keep people watching to the
end how can you hold viewer attention
and don't click bait now let's talk
about it
don't click bait click bait will make
your bounce rate sore and
algorithms will hate you because you
might get a lot of clicks right away but
then youtube goes well the
satisfaction's not there because no
one's sticking with the video they
you potentially trick somebody now
clickbait's a confusing term
because sometimes clickbait
seems like it's good like it could
actually denote
that someone clicked on it it grabbed
attention
there's a confusing that like good
marketing like just a a great thumbnail
and a great title like oh it's such a
great title it's click that it doesn't
necessarily mean
it's clickbait the definition though
usually universally
and the way that wikipedia would define
it is that it's a false advertisement
it is deceptive sensationalized
and ultimately misleading that is what
you don't want to do
because not only will that hurt your
reputation in the algorithm it'll hurt
your reputation with people
i am all for sensational titles
so long as they are followed by
sensational content
and in that case it would not be false
advertisement it would be
a good advertisement for a good video it
would not be deceptive
you would be backing up a really
powerful promise in your title
with really powerful content and so
my question for you is do you think it's
okay to click bait
and have you ever attempted to click
bait with your content
let me know and here's a thought
don't click bait click
bless like bro
i'm a dad now i've been a dad for a
couple months and the dad jokes
but i'm serious don't click bait
click bless so what i mean you want to
you want to attract
the click but people should be blessed
after watching the content
not bait and switch not misled by
the content let me know on a scale from
1 to 10 how cheesy
that quote was i i thought i would just
try that one out don't click bait
click bless you gotta get the click
but then hopefully people are blessed by
the content when they watch it
afterwards that brings us to number four
and then i got three super powerful tips
to summarize it all these are just all
the quotes directly from youtube
number four this is how youtube
determines what to recommend we
also ask users directly about their
experience with individual videos
and our recommendation systems using
random surveys that appear
on their homepage and elsewhere
throughout the app we use this direct
feedback to fine-tune and improve these
systems
have you ever seen one of these surveys
i got one on my smart tv the other day i
watched a casey neistat video and a
survey popped up and it gave me
the ability to rate it on a scale from
one to five to see if i liked it
so i'm sure that video algorithmically
was was being
suggested but just because this is kind
of like
a safety net for youtube just because
people are watching a lot of something
doesn't actually mean that they
necessarily enjoy it or that they're
satisfied by it they might actually have
watched it
they reached the end and they go that
sucked but maybe a lot of people are
being tricked
you know because like it's like click
bait and click
bait content but eventually it just like
leaves you
empty at the end the promise was never
met and fulfilled you're like i just
wasted 10 20
50 you know 30 minutes my life so
youtube interjects these surveys to try
to get data
that you might actually finish a video
and and then be like it was terrible
so then they might throttle that video
away here's the deal they say
they're fine-tuning and improving the
systems by using these actual surveys
let me know if you've seen them i've
seen them on my smartphone
i've seen them on my desktop they play
after videos they play like in
sometimes just in the feed i said
they're everywhere i don't see them that
often though so i'm curious how often
you see those
so that's the last one of that and i'm
excited we're gonna get into three tips
in just uh a second here of um
for summarizing and getting your videos
recommended by youtube but if you've
been getting value
hit that like button and remember
today's video is brought to you by
tubestarterkit.com i'm so pumped
about this holiday special we've never
done anything like this 90 off of our
power packed template and tutorial
bundle
um we cover titles thumbnails
monetization video ideas
and helping you really get clear on your
youtube game plan
and probably the most important thing
included in the starter kit is our
clarity blueprint
it's about 10 pages of really helping
you
understand the viewer helping you
through some practices through some
thinking through some questions
because the creator who understands the
viewer best wins and so
tubestarterkit.com
if you haven't checked that out yet link
in the description down below three tips
for getting your views recommended
number one is competition is a good
thing
competition is a good thing if you're
starting youtube right now or you're
wondering can i still grow on youtube in
2021
you got to know that as youtube said
they look at your watch history and
search history and channels you're
subscribed to therefore
you should be creating content in a
proven and appropriate popular niche if
you want to really grow on youtube
because if people love watching a
particular type of content they'll want
to watch more of it
therefore competition is a good thing
but
different is better than better so how
can you be in a proven and profitable
niche
niche but then how can you be different
in that niche here's one of my favorite
examples
if you haven't heard about camera
conspiracies casey
is crushing it on this channel it's one
of my
uh favorite camera channels i his videos
were recommended to me
because uh and he's getting around half
a million views a month right now
growing by 2 500
subscribers a month he actually has a
main channel called vegetable police
uh where he talks about health stuff and
some workout stuff and and that was kind
of his main thing
then he started getting into this i
searched for the perfect camera
now here's my point competition is a
good thing
you know how many camera channels there
are now like you know how you probably
know you're like you know me tech
channels that are all
you know how many people are talking
about cameras covering the latest camera
you know these days something like when
i remember when the sony zv1 came out
and like the day it came out my
subscription feed
was filled with like every single tech
channel like instantly like when a new
product's released
that could seem discouraging because
you're like man there's so much
competition how can i break through in
my niche
well what i love just as camera
conspiracies as an example
is it's a proven niche there's a seth
godin
tribes one of our top recommended books
there's a group of people with a shared
interest
and a way to communicate which is
youtube they're all learning about
cameras and watching channels like
think media or whatever um and so
there's already
and and cameras in my opinion is
becoming like a subculture it's almost
like sneaker culture like
you know i don't know about you you know
we're like you're thinking about your
setup thinking about your lenses
thinking about what's in your camera bag
like it's a whole subculture
so he shows up quote unquote late to the
game
and but brings a completely unique spin
to camera talk humor
really contrarian perspectives mainly
humor
kind of satire but backed up with a lot
of
legit camera knowledge and kind of just
bringing people along on his journey to
find the perfect camera
when a lot of camera and tech review
channels
are pretty similar he's different
and it really is just being himself so
my question is how can you be you times
two
how can you maximize your unique traits
and your unique personality
not being afraid of competition actually
running straight
into an arena of competition but
thinking about
how can you be different because as
sally hogg's head said in the famous
book
different is better than
better he didn't have to beat any tech
channels he just
was himself with his camera
channel and uh it's really been working
and i think there's a lot to learn there
tip two
the creator who understands the viewer
best
wins so how can you really drill down on
understanding the viewer
but listen and understands their subject
matter
so it's not just about understanding the
viewer but you also need to understand
your arena and your subject matter
there's something about be staying in
your lane too i'd like to say
because why is camera conspiracy is
doing well
i think with just the humor and just
being contrarian
he could do pretty well i think one of
the reasons he's doing really well
is he really understands cameras like
many of us he's a true camera geek
a true camera fanatic reads blogs reads
so
he really understands the subject matter
so he brings value to it
i don't think you can master a lot of
things but i want i'd like you to think
about what can you really go deep on
maybe out of your multiplicity of
passions you're trying to figure out
your niche
what can you really drill down on and
really understand your subject matter
because by the way
to even understand the viewer you need
to understand the subject matter
like to even understand the way the
viewer could be thinking you
here's the best thing to do is to be in
a niche that you're absolutely obsessed
with yourself what do you study
what do you love to learn about what do
you love to read about what will keep
you fascinated
what what do you keep learning about my
friends i continue
to dive into my niche of wanting to
understand and master youtube
i've been talking about this thing for a
while man already got the gold play
button
could chill out a little bit now even
based on some of the results we've
gotten
but i actually love my subject matter
plus
i want to continue to keep winning on
youtube so i keep studying
the subject matter so much so that we're
talking at length
about the youtube algorithm which i
continue to study
and and i also think man i'm not going
to try and start a personal finance
channel
because dave ramsey robert kiyosaki
graham stefan
meet kevin like they their knowledge and
how far ahead they are like i would have
to
restart learning but dude i've been
doing videos since 2003 dawg
i've been doing you know what i mean
like i have my thing and i just keep
going deeper with one thing there's
something powerful
about really getting momentum and it'll
help you understand not just the viewer
but understanding your subject matter
and continuing to level up on your
subject matter
practical tip i would order
the best two to five books either on
audio
book physical book or ebook of your
subject matter
to study alternative i don't read and
people don't write books
subscribe and turn on notifications on
your laptop or your computer
to the top blogs the top thought leaders
in your subject matter you got to stay
on the front cutting edge of your
subject matter
because that's where the best ideas will
come from it'll also
allow for you to actually have integrity
in your content and that's where you'll
be able to hack the youtube algorithm
and start getting recommended
because when the viewer watches your
stuff he goes oh she understands the
subject matter
and what you're even talking about is
informed because of how deep
you are in your subject matter and aware
of what's going on and in my my opinion
you can't understand 40 different
subjects
because it would be hard to keep up on
all of those that therefore niching down
is super powerful just a recommendation
tip number three
content is king content is king if
you're gonna hold viewer attention to
the end
you gotta understand content content is
king but
marketing is queen and she runs the
household
so not only in 2021 do you need a master
creating content
you gotta master modern marketing i hope
you're subscribed to our channel the
think
marketing youtube channel and our
podcast the think marketing podcast
let me know if you've been listening we
have weekly episodes every tuesday
you gotta understand marketing because i
think it's mastering and understanding
the art of getting attention hooks
um and understanding holding of
attention
and then also how to create content we
talk about both on that channel and on
think media
content is king but marketing is queen
and she
runs the household
coming up is how youtube works series
is coming up soon and um in part three
we're going to talk about monetization
how youtube pays you
the highest cpm niches tips for getting
1 000 subs and 4 000 hours of watch time
so you can get monetized
um and so make sure to subscribe for
this series let me know
what was your biggest aha moment from
the training today in the comment
section below
i'm not sure if we've shared out the
coffee with cannell link but we'll do
that soon
um and uh i'm excited for you to come on
the show today we'll be able to answer a
few questions
um but smash like if you got value and
what do you need to do
next when it comes to your channel and
your content
um when it comes to hacking the youtube
algorithm sky blue jeans what's the
difference between think marketing and
think media
we saw the need to kind of
um create a fork in the road
of two related youtube channels that uh
have kind of two distinctions to them
with think media talking about
cameras um and tech
and how to create video content not
everybody watching that necessarily
wants youtube advice
so what we were sort of spinning off
with think marketing
is that that's more of the marketing and
the strategy side
and think media is more of the tech and
the camera side now
for anybody that's really a deep part of
our community you might be like
blurry lines bro i mean robin thicke
like it's like
it seems like there's a lot of overlap
well because of
really still being in less than a year
old on think marketing
we are kind of overlapping
to help if you will migrate those who
would raise their hand and say
i specifically want to learn the
marketing side i want to master modern
marketing i want to learn how to build a
business around my youtube channel
i want to go deeper and ultimately on
think marketing we're going to be
talking about
youtube is like the lenses that you view
everything through that we view
everything through
but to build a youtube business
splinters off into all kinds of things
how do you eventually maybe build a
website how do you build a media kit for
brand deals how do you build an email
list what are the best crms
and email softwares you know you start
sharing out
all those different types of details and
so
um how do you maybe make an online
course
package promote and profit from your
knowledge and so
that's the difference between think
marketing and think media and we're
really dialing those in
and to be super clear um the difference
between
think marketing and think media um is
the think marketing podcast
so one of the biggest topics we think is
super important right now
is video podcasting and starting a show
so we started a weekly show
we knew we wanted to be on youtube and
be consistent so the main point of the
think marketing youtube channel was
actually just
the tuesday think marketing uh podcast
we've now started other shows here like
coffee with cannell this show
we've started think marketing live with
heather we upload
other things occasionally but it was
really a place for our video podcast to
live
our podcast lives on spotify it lives on
google and
apple and it lives on the think
marketing youtube channel and it was
actually because of adapting and
pivoting
to the pandemic that we even started
these shows i hope you've enjoyed coffee
with kennel it started when we were like
shoot we're locked down all my travels
canceled
and so how can we um get into some
things
uh like this uh if you want to join me
on um the show today uh the link is
being posted
in the youtube live chat and you can
come on make sure you got good audio
make sure you got lighting
or you know a decent internet connection
and uh would love to
uh jump into some of your questions
today but from it up says any tips
to better study your niche when it's
specific
i think what are the best
channels on youtube creating the content
you want to create or what content is
performing well on youtube and what can
you learn from it
immersion in your niche i'm old school
like before just the internet
so it would be like publications
periodicals and magazines like
industry news like for example video
maker magazine
comes to my house you know what i mean
so like if you're gonna be
deep in your niche although this stuff
is all online much faster
like i'm immersed in my industry i go to
nab
i go to ces they're gonna be digital
this next year i think
um this is this is a physical magazine
like what are we talking about in 2021
but that's that's that's what i would
say and so
if you could learn anything from my
behavior i subscribe to
blogs i get notifications i listen to
industry news
i want to be emerged i pay attention to
other voices
in my niche and go to events
watch events online total immersion like
surround yourself
and that helps you understand your topic
and
your content all right um smash like if
you've been getting value out of
coffee with cannell today and we've got
allison
clark on the show how's it going allison
where are you from and what's your
channel about
great uh i just started my channel i've
well i've had a channel for a while but
i just started uploading i'm doing the
vra
um and i do youtube
videos for my corporate business
uh so i thought this would help me and i
was just wondering
how you see the future of uh
video in the next few years and where
that's going
well that's an awesome question and
thanks so much for being a part of the
vra fam
and tell me about your business uh well
right now i mean i just
uploaded a couple of short videos uh
they're just tips and tricks
uh really easy word uh
word i guess quick tips
because i get asked things like how do
you do a hyperlink at my office
or little things and i thought hey you
know what if my co-workers are asking me
this
a lot of other people are going to be
asking so that's what i've done on my
channel
uh that's microsoft word yeah microsoft
word
i love that because um just and i'll
answer your other question as well but
you know when you do like how to do a
hyperlink in word i see a couple things
you know this video has 434 000 views
this video has 234
000 views and these are old right this
is four years old this is five years old
dethroning these videos might be a
challenge but i think that following of
course the strategies we teach
um in vra uh you have a lot of
opportunity to build up a library of
videos that
sometimes i mean it's a minute 39 this
is three minutes and 10 seconds
and so you're definitely doing the
strategy of answering specific questions
my thought would be how can you make
thumbnails and maybe word a title that's
yes very search based but that just sort
of has
a little um pizzazz to it a little bit
of
pumpkin spice on the whipped cream not
just
not just the pumpkin spice latte but the
whipped cream and a little spice on top
and those videos could really do well
for you but man the future of video
that is a massive question um but
i think a couple things to know video is
king
and that fact has been completely
established therefore investing in video
is a wise invested
meaning years ago that social media
examiner uh determined
that video is people's preferred content
format of choice
if you think about instagram has now
added video
and tons of video reels stories live
video
igtv you think about linkedin you used
to not be able to do video there now
video is huge there stories
you think about platforms like tick tock
short form video is a major trend
but video overall streaming platforms
meaning like kind of ott over the top
hulu disney plus
type of platforms are on the massive
rise right now so just video content in
general
is the now and it's also the future
so it's really not going anywhere i
think vr and things like that will
eventually come around
but that's further off than maybe we
think
and so on a general level um even not
just my opinion but someone i super
respect
uh mr beast even talked about he's like
i'm going all in of course he's going
all in on youtube but he's like i expect
youtube
2025 to look pretty similar just at a
larger scale
to what it looks like now because
there's more adoption
of um the consumption of video content
and then i think the last thing
is that right now is a very strategic
time it can feel kind of overwhelming
and here's the deal the fact is
like all these videos these
five-year-old videos people are talking
about how to do a hyper
lincoln word so it can be kind of like
shoot i'm late to the game
however um the pandemic
stats from it revealed that a lot of
adult social media use doubled
and a lot of different generations
started adopting
social media use more than ever before
for example i couldn't
ever get my mom to even watch an
instagram story now
she started watching them but then she's
like they disappear i don't i don't even
have a chance to watch it i'm like mom
you can just like re-watch the
but like so you just think about the
long tail of adoption
of even people starting to become part
of youtube culture video culture
and so the future of video is bright
i think that to win in this next decade
on youtube it's important though to
really
dial in on strategy like when youtube
started if you were playing checkers
you could win but if you want to win in
2021 and beyond you really have to be
playing chess
mastering strategies thinking about how
to be different a lot of the stuff we're
already talking about and you're part of
our community so we're obsessed with
staying on the edge
of that but those are just some of my
thoughts uh about video any um
any thoughts on on those ideas i just
want to give you some feedback i
uh watched your the camera confidence
and i utilized some of those tools or
some of those
tricks onto the corporate uh
side the youtube corporate uh channel
and um we are at 700
subscribers and we only had like 150 or
200
like two months ago so we're we're
getting up there and uh i'm hoping in
the next few months
we'll be able to do something with that
uh that will be beneficial for the
company so
that's amazing allison i appreciate that
feedback and heather will love to hear
that you got massive value out of camera
confidence we love
that um course that's a part of vra and
congrats 150 to 700 subs is no joke
and youtube is like a fine wine it gets
better with age
yes it's like unlike this exactly yeah
so um i think one
as we land the plane on this idea as
well i see it happen a lot and i don't
blame people for this
but it's really easy to start youtube
and get discouraged and give up
it's easy to potentially even go hard
for a month three months some people go
hard for six months even a year
i've so noticed uh you know having the
blessing of being able to do video
influencers for years i remember we
talked to
andrew edwards where we interview all
these different youtubers even
who started in 2010 right he said
oh no it's actually barnacules nerdgasm
that's what the channel is called
and he's really super known for
different tech and like kind of like 3d
printing and different creative stuff
now he um said that for
six years his channel was kind of just
like blah
but in year seven boom is when it it
clicked for him and it really took off
now our hope is that being connected to
our community things can go faster and
we help people go
further faster but nevertheless the
the snowball effect of youtube once you
start dialing it in it so gets better
with age and some of my friends and
other business owners
the day-to-day tyranny of the urgent and
the fires you got to put out
put out kind of take away from staying
consistent with that weekly upload but
if you can get a system implemented into
your business your life
where you're putting out good content as
consistent as possible hopefully once a
week
it's a cumulative effect and uh
it can lead to massive massive things
because of the momentum that the youtube
algorithm
creates well thank you so much
absolutely allison thanks so much for
coming on coffee with kendall today
thank you sean appreciate you hey smash
like if you are pumped about the future
of
video what trends do you see what
predictions do you see
i think uh that'd be a cool video to do
what's what are some of the we usually
do that 2021 what are the
most current stats and numbers but every
year it goes up more businesses more
marketers
more adoption of businesses last that i
read though
is that less than nine percent of small
businesses
in the u.s use youtube that's the last
that i just read it on neil patel's blog
it might be higher now and i'm sure
we're helping it become higher
at think marketing and think media but
it's still a small number
i think that's because sometimes organic
content on youtube
is hard to make work for local but i
think we need to start having more
global strategies no matter what we're
doing
we need to be thinking about a global
connected world because the internet
connects all of us and at least connects
us globally
so all that to say the future of youtube
in the future of video is bright friends
and so uh keep pressing in keep crushing
we got dennis from scratch on coffee
with candle today dennis break down
your channel and uh how can i help
hey sean uh yeah so my name is dennis
russell i run
a channel called dennis from scratch
that teaches
nutrition focused cooking um
so i go over like tips on how to get
nutritious ingredients and then also
a little bit of how to cook them and my
question
is two questions first i also
have a comedy channel that is older i've
been doing that for about a year
and i'm just wondering you talk about if
you're doing it
part-time focus on one channel
but i actually have the advantage that i
have a lot more time
so i'm able to devote kind of a
full-time career towards youtube
is it advisable that if i can get a
video out each week
i can keep doing the two channels or
what do you suggest do i hone in on the
one channel for now awesome question
and love what you're doing and thanks so
much for coming on uh
you know coffee with kennel today i mean
here's
here's my advice
i'm gonna get some printer paper i'm
gonna get a sharpie
and gonna let's break it down so
completely fair i'm glad you say that
like okay let's say you can
devote more time how much time
how much time a week do you have to
devote towards youtube
uh lately i've been about 30 to 40 hours
a week
okay so we have 40 hours
and i want to encourage everybody
watching to consider
this same thing for you how many hours a
week do you have to work on your youtube
channel
whether it's 4 or 40 define that number
tell me in the chat how many hours uh in
the comments do you have to work on it
okay
so that's 40 box cars if we thought of
it you know like a
a railroad track and you have each one
of those hours could be devoted to
research they could be devoted to um
shooting they could be devoted to
editing and the more time you spend
editing
maybe you cut out more fluff yeah you
animate the video a little bit so it
holds attention whatever
making thumbnails they also could be
devoted to study and maybe
this is actually creation time and not
study time but studying how the youtube
algorithm works watching think marketing
reading youtube see like whatever you're
doing and so you only have
40 hours not only that's awesome
but define how many hours you have each
one of
the hours is like a box car the problem
becomes
when it when starting to youtube
channels whether you have
very limited time or even if you have a
lot of time
is you're splitting your focus still if
you try and chase two rabbits you end up
catching
neither and so it's this idea where if
you have
let's let's translate 40 into just one
out of 10.
10 is maximizing all your time energy
let's even say creative energy and like
emotional strength
because we're not robots so sometimes
doing creative content too
we we only have so much focus we only
have
so much mental strength come on somebody
can i get an amen when you're like i got
the time i'm not even tired
but my brain hurts i just can't come up
with anything right now
so on a scale from 1 to 10 if you only
have 10 summarized
units of energy my problem is if you got
channel one
and you were to build on it you go
one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten that's how much
impact you could make
would be if you devoted it all into one
channel but
if you had two channels and for the
people watching right now
that are crazy that are like i got four
passions i got four channels it's even
worse for you
um if you end up saying okay well my
main channel is gonna get
six of these but in the other box cars
i'm gonna end up putting
you know four over here then you're
ultimately if this is your destination
you're delaying how long it's going to
take for you to get there
because you are splitting your energy
you're splitting your focus
um and the final thing
to add to the conversation is
the concept of leverage
meaning there's nothing like having a
successful youtube channel
to create a second successful
youtube channel let's use the example of
the wu-tang clan so the wu-tang clan
you're like where's he going
so if anybody knows the wu-tang clan is
a hip-hop rap group
famous kind of founded by rizza nine
original founding members
shaolin new york and they decided to
band together
to create uh rap music
and a unique style and they
had a a long-term plan and the plan was
we're going to create
one thing and we're going to get the
wu-tang clan successful first
then out of it the individual members
will be able to have their own
projects and we'll be able to use the
death star energy come on star wars fans
where you have like a laser beam of
energy
that can blow up planets like we're
going to be able to use the wu-tang
energy
to blow up each of the individual
projects
because we're stronger together but
we're going to focus on making the main
thing
strong first this has actually
influenced my strategy at
think media and even my approach to
youtube in general
once you've built influence it's so much
easier for you to point an audience
somewhere else
there's a reason think marketing has
grown
to over 20 000 subscribers in a
relatively short time
we didn't start it from scratch we
started it from think media we didn't
start it from scratch we started it from
video influencers now you might be
saying sean
well you've got multiple channels yes
but over time
and even with multiple team members
helping me
but i had to focus on the one thing
first and i'll be honest this comes out
of my own pain
i did this wrong when i started i had my
sean cannell channel my clear vision
media channel my think international
channel
my think media channel and at video
influencers might have and i went slower
because of it
it wasn't until i got focused to realize
wait the way i make money and the way
i'm going to get freedom
to even have more time or work on other
projects is by
talking about tech on think media and
ranking videos
and that is the sole focus i gotta i
gotta get my
gusher i gotta get this trickle this
little stream
into a river into a gusher first i got
multiple streams of income
is some potentially a bad thing if you
try to do it at once
let's get one thing going one income
flow one
channel one momentum thing going and so
when you put all your creative energy
into dennis from scratch you start
getting some videos that are getting
sucked into the algorithm
you get more videos that are sucked into
the algorithm the big temptation
is six months into it you go okay this
is the time sean's talking about when he
should split his focus
nope you really want that thing crushing
potentially
10 20 30 40 000 subscribers i would
think
i'd prefer a hundred i think a hundred
thousand subscribers is the target you
should shoot for
before you really start a second channel
i think that when you have that kind of
momentum
because think about the death star of a
hundred thousand subscribers you write a
cookbook
boom bestseller you write you know you
start a second spin-off channel
some people enough people are paying
attention that they want to watch your
vlog or your comedy channel now
and it's gonna be the quickest path not
just to youtube success
this is the quickest path to financial
freedom the quickest path to revenue
the quickest path to all the things
because you take
your 40 i don't care if you got 80 box
cars you just put them
all towards one thing and really to
hammer this point home let me give you
this final
thought is i have 12 full-time people on
the think media team now
so that's like something to keep in mind
video influencers
has part-time people kind of virtual
assistants guadalajara mexico gabby and
gabe and different people that are
helping us
and benji and i do that very part-time
as a side project but we also have benji
gabby jordan gabe and sean that keep
that project going
we've got think media and think
marketing that's 12 people
and so with the amount of resources i
have
i've got money in the bank i've got the
ability to hire more
contract do whatever i need to do i have
this channel sitting there called sean
cannell
not unlike your channel called dennis
russell
i've got 1.4 million subscribers 600 000
on video influencers
um think marketing is 22 000
and as we approach a new year
one of the things i want to do more than
anything is really start investing in my
sean cannell channel just my personal
brand channel
what i want to talk about there is
business and leadership from a faith
perspective
i want to write books about business
leadership
faith i want to really impact men
and leaders of families to be leaders
it's a lot of things i want to do
and i oftentimes find myself daydreaming
and getting
uh losing focus of like my main business
the thing that employs and feeds
people's kids and does all kinds of
things
and so i started thinking i was like you
know what 2021
that's the year where i'm gonna focus
i'm gonna start going into it
it's gonna be the beta year slept on it
prayed about it all these different
things
and then i was like dude assignment 2021
and it might not be 2022. this is for me
of course you with all of this advice
you could take it with a grain of salt
but i was like man it's still
dude we've only we haven't even been
doing the think marketing podcast for an
entire year and i'm going to start
something
different man you got to keep doing the
same thing
keep compounding your energy keep
compounding the momentum
when think media has so much momentum
about 40 million views a year
it would be easier to get think media to
80 million views a year
doubling my channel because the momentum
we have than actually growing another
channel from scratch because of momentum
and staying in that lane and staying on
the brand
this is one of the biggest
entrepreneurial dilemmas and youtube
creators are entrepreneurs that i think
a lot of us face
but this i think is one of the most
powerful concepts if you can define how
much time you have
and then with the power focus and
blinders on
focus that time potentially month after
month and even year over year
to build an asset for you that
once you got an editor going once you
got videos ahead in the batch
once you yeah once you're once you can
take two months off because of how many
scheduled uploads you have
once you've got passive income coming on
once you have all that stuff coming in
then maybe start your dennis russell
channel with a lot of energy
and then maybe even still don't because
then double dentist for scratch
write your second cookbook and blow that
one up get it even
crazier that's the power of focus
it's self-awareness ultimately because
it's your tube
it's youtube so if you want to have a
hobby channel or a comedy channel
or you want to chase two rabbits at once
then by all means do it but my best
advice
is compound and focus all of your energy
on one thing against one target
don't be a shotgun blast be a laser
towards
your predefined goal reverse engineer
everything based on where you want this
to go
and then invest all your energy there
what are your thoughts uh dennis has
this been helpful
yeah that's really helpful um just gives
me a lot of clarity
um i yeah i think that makes a lot of
sense
i will focus on dennis from scratch
because i see that one as having the
more
um the more potential for
business than starting a comedy channel
uh my second question is kind of along
those lines of building
income from this you've talked about
like product reviews and there's a lot
of products i could review
you know waffle makers blenders whatever
i want to do that's part of that cooking
niche
but i don't have affiliate marketing yet
and so i'm wondering
when is a good time to start doing those
product reviews to start
making that affiliate income because i
know i can't like
sign up when i have zero views for
affiliate marketing
yeah 100 so you're doing it you're doing
it exactly right
point number one influence comes first
income comes second
once you start getting the influence a
whole other reason
just to reinforce why not splitting your
40-hour boxcars
why you should keep them all in one line
because the sooner you get to a tipping
point of influence is the sooner
every affiliated program approves you
and and assume
that you have enough traffic to actually
make real money from affiliate marketing
so tip one
focus on making your best videos focus
on getting as many views as possible
focus on yeah and again instead of two
videos on two different channels
two videos a week on this channel
because that'll have you closer to
having one of those break out
tip your subscribers your growth your
awareness so
influence comes first income comes
second then secondly
once that happens then start signing up
for relevant affiliate programs
but the way i i naturally think these
might not be
all of your ideas from the channel but i
like to play things out
and try to reverse and reverse engineer
them from how could this be a million
dollar brand
i mean it's big think but like that's
that's what we do it think marketing and
think media so we think big
and so it's like how could this be a
million dollar brand so i would be
eventually thinking
how do i have a cookbook how do i have
downloadable
pdf uh recipes that are maybe printable
that cost seven dollars or twenty seven
dollars as a digital product eventually
how do i uh partner with a subscription
box um
of cooking spices monthly and do brand
deals with them or just do affiliate
links
to a subscription box how do i sign up
of course for amazon or maybe
a cooking cast iron pan pot and pan
type of affiliate deal uh and and link
to those various ones and have rank
videos reviewing kitchen sets and
whatnot
um i could cover you know you could do a
friday gadget series
there's a question how do i go to three
videos a week i've got my
uh how to make chicken stock like a
cooking tutorial
i've got like nutritional awareness good
eggs versus bad eggs and then i've got
like
kitchen gadget of the week show and
eventually
the kitchen gadget of the week show
again it's f if you're not
approved for an affiliate account and a
lot of people ask this
well i don't have enough views yet
should i not even make the video because
i can't sign up yet i don't have enough
views
you have which comes first the chicken
or the egg in this case
the chicken the chicken has got to get
to work and make some videos and get the
influence first
so even if you made 10 20 30 without
monetizing them
gadget of the week videos it builds
momentum into the show
because you're building for life
eventually this is a million dollar
brand
and so you then have your gadget of the
week show
eventually brand deals because now the
influence is there and then maybe
eventually like a cookbook
or a cookie you know that's actually
printed with the traditional publisher
and then maybe eventually you're
crossing over onto um you know
traditional media and you're on the
cooking network of course this should
all be reverse engineered
back from your ambition but in a lot of
ways those were some very practical
monetization strategies but i hope to
bring it back
in this whole conversation to putting
blinders on again
focus follow one course until successful
focus and focus on influence focus on
your next best video click through rate
average view duration
and being even patience patient in the
process which i believe that you are
you've only been at this for five months
like you're a lot you know
which is a while but what
we just painted potentially a 10-year
vision
what's it gonna be worth when all of
that momentum kicks in
at a year and a half when things get
really crazy
at three years and then think when
things are unbelievable
at year six you wanna really get that
snowball of
influence first and then you're going to
be blown away by all the income
opportunities that show up on the other
side
awesome well thank you so much that is i
i love the three
different types of videos per week that
you gave me talking about ingredients
talking about gadget of the week and
cooking tutorial i think that's
something i'm going to implement
but that's really awesome bro well hey i
appreciate you thanks for coming on
coffee with kennel today
thank you sean cheers all right hey
did you get some value out of that
friends that was a fun conversation
and um let me know how many videos are
you posting a week
and what topic categories are they in
one of the things we just did with
dennis from scratch was potentially
put certain types of videos and
categories like on think media
we have tech reviews we have tech
tutorials how to use a camera
we have general video tips every friday
on think media
we upload uh like a youtube strategy
video and usually a clip
from one of these coffee with channels
or the opening training
uh our think marketing bucket and topic
of content is every tuesday the new
think marketing podcast
episode comes out organizing your
content into categories can be really
really helpful
and so for these are my thoughts say you
know once a week
taste test and games i love that wow
self retired doing six to seven videos a
week that's insane
um let's see posting on creating digital
prod products sabrina says awesome
um that's interesting you know sabrina
you could be doing things like
um software review and you know one week
it's like kartra
next week it's click funnels next week
it's kajabi and it's like a show like
helping people pick
for digital products like different
categories it could be
um of course how to you know breaking
down digital products
how to build an email list first and
that's like tips on
whatever and then like actually how to
create your products market research
but i love thinking in in terms of shows
you know like what the coffee with
cannell is a show
think marketing live with heather is a
show and when we say show we don't got
any music we don't got any logos except
for this think logo
that stream yard is able to put on and
off up here right
um and and so we just kind of want to
serialize and showitize what
um our content so let me know what kind
of content
and how your content fits in different
buckets smash like if you're getting
value
i have to go make a deposit in escrow in
just a second here
um but i think we could probably get in
uh another
coffee with kennel we got william on the
show today william tell me where you're
from and what your youtube channel is
all about
hi everyone i'm william i live in france
and i think
i'm a vra student too
and awesome yes i live in france
so i speak french but i really
understand english so i'm going to look
after my words but don't worry i'll try
to explain what i want to talk about
today
so my channel is about youtube and
marketing strategies
because i got a degree in marketing and
social media strategies
and my main focus is on youtube because
i think this is the best platform
in the world for real and i'm also
photographing videographers so sometimes
i talk about like omar does
i talk about the video tips tricks to
have better lighting better videos
better image quality
and i just want to focus on my efforts
on youtube because in france there are
several videos talking about videos and
views but they
they want we don't have channels that
talk about
um yes this is my channel so we don't
have channels that talk about
um youtube marketing specifically
so i just want to put my focus on on
this and build up some momentum
for with my channel i love it um
i want to hear your question in a second
but think marketing
crew and coffee with kennel crew i love
this
because this is obviously i mean this is
what we're talking about right now this
is what i do as well but william
is doing it in french there's so much
opportunity
to be doing potentially local content
for a certain language
for a country and for doing something
that's proven something that's
profitable but something that's niched
down i wouldn't understand these videos
you're getting thousands of viewers you
already have 2 000 subscribers that do
understand videos because they're
friends in fact i mean eight bit uploads
a month
uh 380 new subscribers that's 52
go for green man 15 000 views 95
so things are going amazing william i
love it well what's your question today
how can i help
yes so my question is um this is i feel
like a little
momentum on my channel so i know you
talk about
specific question but i don't want to
turn my channel
only into how to content because
sometimes i think you have to talk about
opinion you have to talk about your
thoughts
about some topics and i just want to
have a balance
because i publish two videos per week
how can i balance how to content
and more more deep content if i can say
that
so that's a great question um i think
it's the age-old question of
do we potentially only create content
that placates
the algorithm that just will get clicked
on and just will get views
or do we create content that is quote
unquote more meaningful
that is also as you said about depth
uh that's more deep yes i think that
that's subjective
still you know because what is deep
really
you know what is meaningful really um
and it's also reverse engineering though
what's your end goal so i would totally
agree
another way to put it would be if i if i
put out a video
if i put out a video with the word
business in the title it actually does a
lot of words
because a smaller group of people think
of themselves as a business owner even
though most youtube creators are
and if i was to talk if i was to put out
a video like five
deep truths i've learned about
business and youtube and then
like parentheses wisdom with sean series
it would probably not do very well
versus one
crazy youtube algorithm hack you know be
it's just different types of titles
people a lot of times want
if you will you know the clickable and i
totally understand where you're coming
from
so a couple thoughts on it thought
number one is
i actually think when you're starting
though to even have permission to talk
about deep
topics sometimes you need to just talk
about popular topics
let me put it another way you should
start with answering the
questions people are asking so you can
eventually get a chance to answer the
questions
that people are not asking like this is
kind of an example
because you know we're like over an hour
into this thing
we're on this long show i'm sipping on
coffee you're in france
we're hanging out the fact you even know
me is because i
started by answering questions people
were asking and if you will
doing videos that led to growth and now
we're able to go deep and talk about
business and dennis and i
just chopped it up about focus and i'm
drawing
charts and you know so so i think
actually
it starts kind of with with first and
then you have the opportunity
to go deep later start with answering
the questions people are asking
and later you'll have a chance to answer
the questions they aren't asking let me
take it even deeper
we talk about stuff people came to our
grow the video live conference
um this year was virtual the year before
it was in person because it's no
pandemic
and people were like i thought i was
coming to grow a video live to learn
about video which i did i didn't realize
like my marriage was going to be changed
that was one of the people
because like when people get close to me
they start realizing
in our whole team man we're like people
of faith we're like people of like
your whole life matters like you're
you're
it starts on the inside it comes to the
outside god's a huge priority in our
life
so that shows up at a different level of
depth
at an event people came to in las vegas
but the reason those people even met me
is because i was answering the questions
they were asking
so maybe i had eventually the
opportunity to answer questions they
weren't asking
so i think that's something to remember
youtube is not everything
in terms of your overall business
strategy youtube is a really good
front-end way to meet people
but can people eventually join an email
list with you where you answer other
questions
could they join a private facebook group
where you do live streams where you talk
about deeper things
could they be invited into an email
newsletter like
what are what is the holistic picture of
people could
self-select if they want to go to a
deeper level with you
and you don't necessarily upload that
in a place where they expect you to just
give them monetization tips youtube tips
and things like that does that make
sense
it makes sense because i i started um
an email list and i had two 250 people
right now
so i'm going to build up and thank you
for everything you do in my life because
you
i told this to my wife every day sean is
my mentor and one day i'll go to vegas
to greet him and say thank you and god
bless you your business your family
thank you for everything
my man william i appreciate that let me
hit you with one more thing
that i want to add to this conversation
though i think what i shared there was
good
but i also want to encourage you and
everybody watching the other thing you
do is to experiment bro
is is like it is your channel and we
i could get just as afraid as you
probably do people are used to one thing
and i'm like i mean if i upload this
other video
like what if people don't click on it
what if it destroys my whole channel you
know you like
you get you get like even if you got 500
subscribers you know somebody and
they're like what if
i talk about something i haven't talked
about yet you always have to give
yourself i think this
it's like the 80 20 rule 80 of your
content in your uploads
should be on brand on stuff that you
know people are really going to click on
you should experiment in the other 20
especially if you're feeling passionate
about it
because here's the thing lob the video
out there if it tanks
if if it does really terrible and if you
just evaluate or if it just does okay
and you go you know what this wasn't the
place for it whatever
like nothing's really lost even even in
maybe a few dislikes or a negative
comment whatever you gotta give yourself
permission to experiment
a little bit because the alternative is
people go
bro i love it when you get deep man i
love it when you talk about stuff like
that the fact you got real and raw
like it could become the biggest thing
and open up a whole nother door
or it could just be flatlined or it
might
you know you might learn some lessons
from it at the end of the day sometimes
you win
sometimes you learn and so give yourself
some permission to experiment
never get too far into a rut
that we create for ourselves so this is
what my channel is about and this is
what my brand is and i'm not allowed to
talk about other stuff
it is youtube it is your tube
it's your channel and people are
definitely not just subscribing
for the youtube tips they're also
subscribing for
you and so at some level give yourself a
chance to maybe
open up a little bit or or experiment
with something
and all of us as we kind of land the
plane we always need to be testing and
evaluating that's the purpose of youtube
analytics
it we can never just post in isolation
if you will or or post apart from
not measuring what gets measured gets
improved
so it's about posting even even the
stuff you're doing
you might need to pivot your strategy
pivot later those who really survive on
youtube continue to reinvent themselves
adapt come with come with fresh content
fresh ideas
they you know so we always need to be
analyzing give yourself a chance to
take a risk talk about something deep
experiment with some kind of topic
and then look at the results and always
be studying your analytics looking for
the winners and how you can tweak and
optimize
because small tweaks lead to giant peaks
yes thank you very much i appreciate you
thanks for coming on
thank you bye coffee
with cannell all the way from las
vegas to france love william
love dennis love allison hey uh
grateful for cj and shane and enman and
aiden
guys thanks for being in the back end i
gotta go to escrow i gotta
i gotta put a check towards a project
and uh
i have a deadline to do that i
appreciate you hanging out today if you
just joined
um watch the replay because we broke
down some stuff
about the youtube algorithm and
specifically how youtube recommendations
work
not my opinion youtube themselves
describing exactly how they recommend
videos
so definitely check out that replay
smash the like button
if you got value today what was your aha
moment more than that what are you gonna
do next
what is what are you gonna take action
on my friend
if you want to win on youtube in 2021
you need the right strategies but you
need to be taking massive action
it's not just about information it's
about implementation
when is your next shoot day type it in
the comments when
are you researching your next videos
type that in the comments
what do you need to take action on next
maybe you're studying something when
are you going to take for those in our
vra community when are you going to
watch
the next module you need to watch when
are you going to fill out your vra
workbook
when are you going to finish that other
course you invested in
when are you making that next
thumbnail i'm here to make you
uncomfortable and give you a kick in the
pants
because the secret to success
on youtube is uploading
videos to youtube
wow getting deep today it's true though
like the secret to success on youtube
is uploading videos on youtube we maybe
discovered with dennis
that instead of uploading on two
channels he could actually put two
videos or
three on his one channel and if you keep
quality high
quality over quantity in 2021
but quantity as well if you can keep
quality high
when you post videos to youtube you can
experience
massive massive growth
how do i get personal help uh
talkwiththink.com
if you didn't know if you want to check
out how you could do more with us
work with us at think media talk with
think dot com
we'll drop a link to that you can book a
discovery call and so
um that's talk with think dot com
and another way to get you know that's
your most personal help
if you haven't watched our masterclass
thinkmasterclass.com link in the
description down below
for that and um i need that kick
to nicey says i hope i said your name
right and so
come on kick in the pants and if you
haven't got it yet
grab our holiday bundle we have a
special holiday
uh special going on on the youtube
starter kit
and so tubestarterkit.com and let me
know if you've picked up the starter kit
right now when will the replay be up to
watch it's immediately up here this
video you can immediately re-watch
especially as
soon as i turn it off it'll refresh and
so uh but tubestarterkit.com
over 90 off for a limited time this is
our holiday special
you have um our 51 money making ideas
you've got our title guide you've got
our video best video ideas list
you've got our clarity worksheet um
definitely definitely check this out
we're super excited about it and it's
only available for a limited time
tubestarterkit.com
black friday cyber monday special
check it out and um it's time to grind
man it is time
to uh punch fear in the face
punch perfectionism in the face and
press record happy thanksgiving for
those
here in the u.s and wherever you
celebrate and whatever you
celebrate as well um super grateful
grateful
for you and hope uh for you as well
fortunate adventures
for your family your community grateful
for you thanks for being a part of these
coffee with kennel streams
and of this community um and
uh alina's been in the chat shout out to
alina on the think media team
she's dropping some knowledge in the
chat if you want to check out
tubestarterkit.com link in the
description
description down below happy
thanksgiving first 1000 hours
happy thanksgiving brendan sparks super
super grateful for you omnipotent lenny
appreciate you great job on starting the
channel 2021 is your year
it's time to get your mind right your
grind on your strategy's right
and get that weekly video up keep
getting one percent better with every
upload
appreciate you so much and uh thanks so
much for being here
our time in life i'm thankful for this
community keeping me
focused follow one course
until successful focus
come on jody thanks so much for being
here i appreciate you god bless
gabe i appreciate you and i can't wait
to see y'all on the next coffee with
kennel
i'm going live on think media on friday
for black friday saturday talking about
uh some cameras and tech stuff monday
for cyber monday
so a lot of live streams are coming up
on our other channel think media
um you'll see those and in the meantime
keep crushing it keep smashing it
and we will talk soon later